les mecs j'aimerais qu'on vienne à ce
que vous avez prévu parce que nous avons
annoncé un renfort de 300 qu'on perde
venant de la région bordelaise vendredi
au mans qu'est ce que vous allez faire
vous voulez pas vous mêler aux
mouvements de l'huile qu'est ce que vous
allez faire alors alors allez-y
logiquement le programme mais c'était le
bon dieu a bloqué les trains je pense je
pense qu'une chose comme vous avez vu là
je ne pense pas que ça soit pour samedi
dommage dommage je pense que c'était un
peu tous les jours sans évoquer des
salariés qui ont bossé toute la semaine
à paris qui en laissant deux en province
je ne sais pas exactement il ya quand
même beaucoup
les syndicats qui sont engagés là bas
mais je vous conseille de réforme
populaire mais restée populaire quand
elles vous disent à la découpe est
important renouer le dialogue
dialogue avec la mairie nadia larguet
glissait la balle c'est tout citoyen
parce que s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît non mais la mine de rien en
faisant ça je rebondis sur ce que vous
venez de dire en faisant ça est ce que
vous pensez pas que vous avez vous
mettre la population à dos il est que
mènera peut-être pas mais on avait
commencé sa ba oui mais non mais il n'y
a pas de dialogue
non mais moi je prévois la solution et
quelles sont leurs sur le suroît l'année
les gars vous avez une députée fonds
débloqués bien viser les amis des
camions à paris les amibes air et une
députée qui est sur le plateau ce soir
madame la députée est ce que vous ne
pouvez pas en tant que député la
république demandé au préfet quand même
ce rôle de médiateur qui les mettent
autour d'une table avec le malade à la
demande on trouve une issue avant il
faut pas qu'ils bloquent ivo samir
haouet alors qu'ils sont dans la
difficulté on voit quelque chose on
attend la députée
marcel à tant de bons commentaires des
lycées richard martel il ya deux
dossiers il ya le mans et puis il ya les
ordonnances et faire des gens moi leur
donnant par exemple je vous ai commencé
un exemple 60 parler uniquement parce
qu'on a le problème des forts un moment
donc je vais creuse et je vous avoue
j'étais pas sur ce sujet je plutôt sur
les sujets tourisme donc je vais vous
lire ensuite sur la ville du mans il
faut qu'on retrouve le talent de la
négociation fut ils font corps aux
médias - mais pour mais je sais on peut
inscrire personne j'ai juste bon et
c'est que tu es ce qu'il pouvait faire
qu'est ce qui pourrait faire que demain
vous suce pour dire à qui il faut
l'avouer avec la mer rendez vous avec la
chine est au rendez vous avec le maire
demain a dit mais je pense que nous
disposons c'est vraiment il ya une
solution
déjà il faut afin france c'est possible
sur tous les postes à combler les gens
autour de la table
donc on peut les mettre je crois que
votre fête foraine au mans s'il n'est
pas déçu pas madame j'ai été dès le 8
avril en août où c'est jusqu'à quelle
date lève le set
donc faut trouver la solution écouter
aujourd'hui je crois vraiment que pour
apaiser le climat est quand même
travailler un petit peu en m'engageant
en même temps déco des négociations
allaient au panorama juste pour cette
fois ci est gagnée quand même de
l'argent et apaisée arrêtons les zones
de la violence qui ne va rien résoudre
alors si oui alors allez-y 4,60 à l'ird
et 10 passes on est habitué ça c'est à
la mairie avec la mairie peut être jeune
et je n'ai pas toujours mais ce que est
ce qu est ce qu est ce qui peut faire
donc comme l'a dit députés comme l'a dit
karim que demain vous suspendez votre
action des concessions alors j'ai donc
des gens qui sont pas la syrie du scud
mon nom mais on a une députée qui vont
peut-être nous avons donc vous m'avez la
médiation ses envies de la wii elle a
envie de la faire un actuellement je
suis présidente syndicat du sud europe
il ya un président de l'intersyndicale
et si je pense que il ya des gens qui
sont responsables syndicaux qui sont sur
place ces gens là ont été invités sont
pas là soit on peut pas parler pour eux
y en a qui étaient en garde à vue
c'est clair on été dit ce matin alors il
sait qu'un volontaire a forcé l'escadron
de gendarmerie
il s'est retrouvé en garde à vue est ce
que c'est la bonne image qu'on doit
donner s'ils voulaient défendre votre
cause
selon ses volontés où j'ai donc cherché
directement ils ont foncé sur le chien
on est paré au plus pressé pour pas et
s'il vous plaît si on perd on se calme
alors est ce qu'il est possible d'avoir
une médiation des deux ment pas pour
qu'on avance pour qu'on puisse avancer
sur cette histoire et pour qu'on puisse
mine de rien dire aux habitants du mont
et de la région que demain ou après
demain il se passera rien est ce que
c'est possible et ce que vous êtes et
long terme de celle ci en capacité de
nous est en capacité de de téléphoner à
ces personnes puis évidemment j'ai leur
numéro j'ai tenté ça hier on pouvait
très bien ça pour ce week-end pour la
deuxièmee j'ai pas du tout envie enfin
moi je rentre au mans et enfin j'ai pas
envie qu'il y ait le feu là bas bien sûr
et c'est pour moi d'ailleurs c'est pour
les gens surtout n'aurait plus que les
gens aient peur parce que franchement la
viande ça suffit à ce chant est tout à
l'heure je reviens sur la violence on
résoud rien avec la violence mais
franchement
visiblement la médiatisation elle est là
s'il ya de la violence exact alors il ya
quand même une petite part de la presse
et des médias de responsabilité excusez
moi de vous le dire moi j'ai un
je peux vous parler tout de suite de
quelque chose qui se passe dans ma
circonscription j'ai eu huit cents
salariés qui vont être mis en
liquidation demain qui travaille dans
une papeterie c'est arjowiggins ils
n'ont pas été violents une que trois
mois ils ne cassent rien personnellement
personne n'est venu recherche 15
millions d'euros d'ailleurs au passage
s'il vous plaît mobilisez vous mais eux
ils ont pas été médiatisée alors je dois
aussi aux médias
oui non monsieur hanouna je demande aux
médias aussi peut-être d'arrêter de
produire cette médiatisation de violence
et de porcs ou alors d'être équitable
d'entracte immédiat de la réputée mois
donnent toutes les prises de paroles que
j'ai eu depuis le début du moins de
gilet jaune j'ai dit que je soutenais
les gilet jaune mais que je condamne et
la violence mais ce soir je soutiens les
forêts mais je condamne la violence oui
mais on peut avoir ce discours
des belges sous les insurgés n'ont pas
non mais attends non mais ça mais
attendez en fait c'est un des sujets à
merville ayasse qu'on peut aller au bout
bon bah oury diallo mais une fois qu'on
a dit ça à 20 dans la lutte et le
pouvoir public ce qu'on appelle à +1 ce
public
vous savez très bien que quand on a des
gens ici ça le drame
certes à un moment donné on rend pas
service à des jeunes comme au mans qui
condamne la violence
si ces gens là demain ils sont hyper
calme ils font pas de bruit on va pas
encore l'avait dit pour les usines on va
vraiment parler et qu'est ce qu'ils vont
faire
ça veut dire que les cours c'est vrai
joachim afin excusez-moi si moi c'est
pascal joachim si si je viens pas là ce
soir on me développe pas le problème des
ordonnances jeu il ya de la violence
vous avez un problème c'est les
ordonnances mais qui on parle
voilà par ce soir devant moi en vase
mais qui nous en parle qui ment pas vous
fier même les forains qui sont venus
voir pour le moment pas parler des
ordonnances
donc voilà on n'est pas non plus sans
sur l'idée que cyril la médiation s'il
vous plaît parce que là je voudrais
clôturé et milieux turcs ont avancé
cette innovation donc est ce que c'est
possible pas d'avoir une médiation à la
question si oui quel aveu oui moi le
député de la nation je la veux pas ce
qu'on pourrait l'organiser dès demain
ben écoutez je ne suis pas mimie mathy
je suis juste petit est blonde donc non
je vais essayer je vais essayer non mais
c'est compliqué quand elle a sorti la
meilleure vente de la soirée
[Applaudissements]
l'opep aliments sans expliquer leur
allée à leur rencontre ne les blocs et
pas moi je suis bonne être exactement
des pommes d'ascension donc là c'est
parce qu'ils veulent ils veulent un
dialogue concret la wimedia nom qui
traitent avec les citoyens oui oui mais
non non non non non alors pas mieux
arrêter de l'irb le kimchi d'abord
alexandre c'est très bien votre peau se
démarque mais on va pas les ennuyer avec
un dialogue citoyen bien sûr qu'il faut
avoir un dialogue avec les citoyens
mais s'ils n'ont pas un dialogue avec
les défricheurs elle va franchement ça
va servir à rien les citoyens ça sert à
rien de commun que les citoyens il faut
d'abord un combat
les gens qui sont en place et trouver
des gens qui peuvent pas se déplacer eux
aussi ils sont emmerdés par l'émotion
rôles c'est nous on pense à tous mais
nous on essaie de les arranger les
citoyens mine de rien hybrides vont
discuter que les citoyens moi je suis
très heureux je trouve que c'est une
bonne idée mais il faut d'abord dé
discuter que les décideurs si on peut se
mettre autour d'une table et si mal à
des paniers que les mecs se tourner pour
trouver des issues assez rapide pour que
les citoyens du monde puisse être
tranquille ce week-end
ça c'est ce qu'on veut et les citoyens
deux ans un travail une semaine alors
faut pas gaspiller ce temps économique
qui est quand même important